hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast 5 steps for publication
quality fixed cell imaging the first
time presented by Jason Kilgore I'm
Kristin Perez and he loves lab routes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
route and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this presentation
is interactive we want to hear from you
questions comments and even answers can
be submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll try
to get to everyone but if not we'll make
sure to follow up with you by email you
can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you cannot hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button in the lower left I will now
turn the presentation over to Jason
Kilgore hello everyone thank you for
attending so I've been with the thermo
Fisher Scientific now since 1999 and
started out in the bio R&D group here
making a number of microscopy based
mainly reagents and kits that
researchers use all over the world now
we're there for about eight and a half
years including leading a lab group and
since then about 2007 I moved over to
technical support and so in a given year
I talked to thousands of you advising
you on how to choose use and
troubleshoot our products so I'm happy
to present this webinar with some of the
advice I've given over the years on how
to make a publication quality image most
of the images that you'll see in this
presentation are ones that I've taken
over the years now what do I mean by
publishable image now naturally you want
an image that conveys whatever
phenomenon that you're studying and the
results but there are some certain
guidelines that
I think you generally want to have for
instance you want to have an image that
has very good signal to background as
good specificity has a bright and
photostable
dye and is able to convey the message
that you need for the results that
you've gotten here for instance are two
examples of some images that at first
glance seem to give you some valuable
information you see some specific
labeling for instance on the top you see
Golgi labeling on the cells at the
bottom you see a brain section with some
Bergmann glia but if you look closely
you start to see some background and
compared to a cleaned-up image an image
that use optimized protocols and
techniques that I'll be talking about
you can see you see a much brighter
signal that compared to the background
and a just a general generally a better
way to get your results let's talk about
some of the processes that are involved
in that now I'm going to talk mainly
about microscopy some of this will apply
to other techniques but for the for this
webinar I'm going to stick to microscopy
and the dyes used for those both for
cells and tissues now we mentioned five
steps to getting a publication quality
image really there five areas and you
can see them listed here and I'll go
through each of those as we talk through
the presentation the first area has to
do with the very beginning just like
building a house you need a firm
foundation upon which to start your
assay and that means the cell and tissue
preparation at the very beginning you
know how you culture the cells how you
fix and perm so let's talk about those
first off you want healthy cells you
never underestimate the value of the
cells that you're imaging at the very
beginning right so let's say you're
culturing cells you want to take a look
at those on a transmitted light
microscope to make sure that
they have the right morphology that
there is no contamination but there
confluency is good for many assays you
want
perhaps a 30 to 60 percent confluency on
a coverslip if you're using tissue you
want to make sure the tissue morphology
is good and so you have to have proper
media serum the nutrients good
temperature and co2 conditions here at
Thermo Fisher Scientific for instance we
have our gift code cell culture side of
the company which sells a lot of these
tools that you need like media so when
you first begin make sure that your
cells are at least your control cells
are as close as possible to their native
physiology and metabolic state so proper
culturing conditions and prior to
beginning your assay here's a list of
some things to really consider you know
examine yourselves make sure that the pH
indicator is not discolored phenol red
is most common and it'll have a pinkish
color
if the pH starts to go off you'll see
that it turns yellowish are the cells of
the proper confluency or the proper cell
number for your assay some assays
require that the cells are totally
confluent and have contact inhibition
going on are the are there any signs of
bacteria or fungi do you have any
strange floaties floating around in your
cells to indicate that there might be
some contamination do the cells have
proper morphology are they shrunken are
they they have weird extended processes
or are they how they're supposed to look
are they blubbing I'll show you an
example of that in other cells well
adhered to the substrate if you are
talking about cultured cells or for
tissue like it's tissue sections make
sure they're well adhere to the slide if
they're not they can come off and that
can cause artifacts I also consider the
you know the basis of your assay do you
need cells in cold
maybe you want to go to what is
increasingly popular a three-dimensional
model up here in the upper right you can
see some images of spheroids for
instance or using our algae matrix to
make a true three-dimensional structure
that's interconnected these are all
considerations to think of before you
begin your assay or right at the
beginning of your M&E imaging protocol
here's some examples of some cells that
aren't really in the best state to start
with in the upper left for instance you
can see a couple of cells labeled with
two fluorescent dyes in the cell at the
top is unhealthy you can see what's
called cell blebbing where the plasma
membrane actually extrudes out into the
media a good sign of cells unhealthier
maybe has the wrong osmolarity in the
upper right or some cells that are
probably going through a photo --ss they
don't like the medium it's in they're
starting to shrink and you see these
weird processes around the outside and
the cell on the left in that picture
actually have nuclear fragmentation
happening now this is a green nuclear
dye called site o 13 and then at the
bottom you can see an example of some
fairly consumed cells that are lifting
off the coverslip that they were
supposed to be adhered to this causes
some distortions that you see because
you can't really focus on the cells that
are not well adhered in the same focal
plane as the others so for some cell
types you need polyol icing or some
other substrate treatment in order to
allow good attachment healthy cells
definitely make for healthy data so have
a good beginning to your process next
and we're talking mainly here in this
webinar about fixed cell systems like
antibody labeling
what does fixation mean well fixation
means that you're doing a chemical
treatment to preserve the cells in a
particular physiological state and to
preserve morphology in
the main way that people do that is
either through a cross linking with
aldehydes or through solvent fixation
cross linking with formaldehyde or
glutaraldehyde really preserves the
structure by cross-linking proteins the
amine groups on these proteins which
creates a rigidity to the cells or
tissue preserving them in that state
just be aware that sometimes by doing
that you can mask antigen binding sites
where the antibody needs to bind and you
have to do an unmasking like an etched
in retrieval or protease treatments in
order to reveal those sites also
increased autofluorescence that is a
fluorescence native to the tissue
increases upon during the cross-linking
glutaraldehyde has twice the
cross-linking powder power but it also
has twice the autofluorescence also you
could instead use a solvent based method
like methanol fixation this permeable
eise's the cells by de lipid izing and
opens up the cells and the antigen
binding sites some antibodies need a
solvent based especially if it's a
nuclear antigen but be aware that does
not preserve the morphology as well as
doing a cross-linking like with
aldehydes you can also lose some
membrane bound components and proteins
or if you label the live cells with a
dye that was a membrane dye like Dai IC
18 it can cause be lost with acetone or
methanol fixation on the left you can
see an example of poor fixation where
the cells actually have this fragmented
appearance to them this is a cell that
cells they are labeled with a phalloidin
to label the f-actin in red on the right
you can see some cells that were
properly fixed you see a nice morphology
and good actin structure to those cells
these were fixed with formaldehyde and I
have a very basic protocol there at the
top basically fixing
somewhere between two to four percent
and usually methanol free is the best
choice formal in for instance is
methanol stabilized formaldehyde so
usually you want to use methanol free on
en grade in fix for about 10 to 15
minutes and PBS or another physiological
buffer at either room temperature or 37
degrees 37 degrees is what I generally
recommend just to make sure in that last
moment before fixation the cells are
still in their proper physiological
state after fixation you would then wash
some cells that you label live are not
technically fixable some might be
retained so I just wanted to make a
point of this if you label live and then
fixed some cells like nucleic acid
stains for instance do not some dyes
like nucleic acid stains do not actually
cross-linked in place and a fixation
won't necessarily preserve them on the
lower left you can see some example of a
tissue that was labeled with three
colors three different fluorescent dyes
and when put at a warm temperature 37
degrees for 14 days the dyes slowly
diffuse off because they're not
cross-linked in place leaving a sort of
washed out appearance some dyes however
are fixable in the upper right for
instance you can see two versions of the
dye at the top of the gallery top left
is a dye called FM 464 on live cells top
right is the SX or fixable version of it
on live cells if you fix the cells the
FM 464 on the left is lost
leading to practically no signal but the
one on the right has amine groups that
are cross-linked in place by aldehydes
and thus retained sometimes you can do a
post fixation as well to cross link
let's say an antibody in place so it's
not lost over time as you archive the
slide remember property
sation means that you preserve your
target for later next you'll permeable
eyes yourselves this is where you
actually poke holes in the plasma
membrane de lipid eyes plasma membranes
such that large molecules can enter this
is very important if you're doing
intracellular targets especially with
antibodies a typical way is to use a
detergent like Triton x100 may be at a
point 1 or 0.2% at room temperature for
5 to 10 minutes sometimes you'll use a
solvent based like acetone to do that
you to do the permeabilization so it's
realize that too much permeabilization
can cause loss of some antigens and the
lipid ation can cause loss of some dyes
especially membrane bound dyes
remember permeabilization actually opens
the door to that those intracellular
compartments after you've permeable eyes
then you go on to your blocking I'll
spend a little bit of time talking here
about the different blocking techniques
usually when you say blocking like for
an antibody you talk about protein
blocking if you use an antibody on
tissue that's not blocked properly that
antibody can bind to proteins other than
the antigen that you're targeting and so
instead you first block with a protein
blocker in many cases this can be bovine
serum albumin or serum like normal goat
serum that's been heat and activated
sometimes out there people will use
others like fish skin gelatin or nonfat
dry milk or commercial and blockers like
blockade I have found that bovine serum
albumin may be at a 6% combined with
maybe a 3 to 5% serum is a very good
combination to knock down some of that
nonspecific binding by the antibodies
however here we sell a component called
blockade which you can purchase at a 1x
concentration
and it's not species-specific I'm like
serum so you can just wash your sample
with that for 30 minutes or so to block
and then you can even use it in with
your primary and secondary to block
those as well on the upper right you can
see some example images of different
blocking conditions compared to each
other this is a cerebellum mouse
cerebellum section cryo section that's
been labeled only with a secondary
antibody with alexa fluor 488 with BSA
or NGS alone you can see that you get a
pretty high signal in the graph there
those are the two left columns BSA and
then NGS normal go serum if you use
blockade you see that you get even less
nonspecific binding and that's a good
thing compared to autofluorescence
protein blocking is very important in
order to make sure that you get a
specific or as close to specific as
possible label you don't want to confuse
with the background now that's protein
blocking and remember that every can did
every assays a little bit different
every cell type is a little bit
different in terms of the optimal
blocking conditions I definitely
recommend optimizing those on your end
now one type of blocking that people
don't tend to realize that they need is
due to dye charge most dyes have a
negative charge on them and because they
are negatively charged they're attracted
to the positively charged areas on the
cells or tissue on cells that's usually
nuclei and mitochondria on tissue that
can be for instance white matter in
brain sections there is a solution
called the image F X signal enhancer
that will block those possibility
charged areas and therefore the
negatively charged dyes won't bind to it
here you can see some examples that in
this image at the top of note
with no blocking versus normal goat
serum only and then labeled only with a
secondary antibody and you can see
although it's a fairly long exposure
time you can see a fair amount of
background there and that's those two
bars in the graph but if you use the
signal enhancer solution you can see
that it knocks it down pretty much to
autofluorescence they're very important
and something most people don't think
about here also is some examples with
that signal enhancer on tissue I
mentioned brain tissue on the upper left
in this image you can see nonspecific
binding by alexa fluor 488 secondary on
that highly charged white matter but
with the signal enhancer it's not down
to just about nothing
very good remember dye charge blocking
means less nonspecific background and
then in addition to the protein blocking
and dye charge blocking there's a some
specialized techniques that require
their own blocking steps as well it's
very common to use a stripped avidin
biotin amplification and I'll talk more
about implicit amplification techniques
in a minute but if you use stripped out
and bite and you want to block the
endogenous biotin in your cells or
tissue first otherwise you'll be
labeling that as well confusing your
signal in the image to the right here
you can see on the left some cells that
have been blocked for endogenous biotin
with one of our endogenous bias and
blocking kits and on the right a cell
that has not been in the cell on the
right you can see you've gotten
nonspecific binding to the endogenous
biotin in the cells mainly in the
mitochondria whereas the picture on the
left that was blocked does not have that
problem and then also if you use an
enzymatic sort of detection like with
Dae or pyramid signal amplification you
want to block the endogenous enzymes and
that mainly tissue
for instance peroxidases if you're using
in horseradish peroxidase or HRP
detection like with diamino benzidine on
your tissue sections or with Terra Minds
you want to do a hydrogen peroxide wash
to eradicate the endogenous peroxidases
before you go through with your labeling
phosphatase is also like for visa pen BT
detection you want to reduce the
endogenous phosphatases with levan as'll
always to get a specific detection okay
so that's blocking one last thing I want
to talk about about cell preparation is
autofluorescence cells and particularly
tissue can have a certain degree of
autofluorescence in it that can confuse
your specific signal and lower your
signal to background here's an image
taken at three different wavelengths and
then combined of a kidney section just
for its native autofluorescence and you
can see in every color there's a certain
degree of autofluorescence there you
don't want this definitely and there's a
lot of different things that can lead to
autofluorescence it could be over
fixation with aldehydes especially
glutaraldehyde it could be the effects
of xylene from your deep paraffin
ization and it could be endogenous
proteins like Lippo fusion which makes
those aged thoughts and old people right
well local fusions inside also in tissue
specially brain or red blood cells or
Auto fluorescent or certain plant
pigments so what do you do about these
Auto fluorescent problems
well first you can do a sodium
borohydride wash this is where you take
sodium borohydride powder that you can
buy from many different chemical
companies including the Fisher side of
our company and then you make it very
freshly at one MIG per mil and PBS and
you wash your tissue or cells with it
three times ten minutes you can see an
example here of how I've knocked down
some background in the red on these
zebrafish paraffin sections
sometimes people will treat their
sections with Soudan black or to quench
the background or photo bleaching it
away with sunlight or strong UV live but
sodium borohydride is usually the best
way to go you can also amplify over the
auto fluorescents and butter
fluorescence is usually fairly dim but
if you're trying to detect a low signal
now the signal to background is a big
problem so amplifying with a
streptavidin biotin or in this case like
I'm showing here amps line with a
terabyte signal amplification kit here
on the left you can see it some tissue
it has a pretty bad autofluorescence in
the green but after amplifying with TSA
I've been able to get a nice clean
signal with the Birdman Lea on these
mouths cerebellum sections you can see
exposure time of only 40 seconds on the
right versus 200 milliseconds on the
left so 40 milliseconds versus 200
pretty much brighter on the right hand
side and then finally there's ways to
use software to remove autofluorescence
for instance you can leave one channel
open hear it for instance I left the red
channel open whereas the Green has a few
very specific spots on it that were
labeled for proliferating cells with an
anti PCNA
antibody on rat liver I then took our
imaging software like our Celeste
imaging software and subtracted the red
background from the green signal and in
the far lower right there you see the
result where you see just a few green
spots where the specific signal is
actually located there's also special
instruments out there from certain
microscopy companies for spectral
deconvolution where single colored dye
samples are used to make a library and
then of dye spectra and then it
subtracts that spectrum from your
specific image remember overcoming
autofluorescence means more sensitivity
to give you a better more publishable
image
about signal to background okay let's go
on to step two here and this is labeling
your sample here we're talking about
labeling with a primary antibody and
optimizations for that using primary
antibodies is a very common technique
and well-established and there's lots of
great references out there about the
many different characteristics of using
antibodies which I won't go into here
but how do you what are some things that
you want to think about in order to get
the most publishable image first off go
with a respected company as your source
for your primary antibody and there's a
lot out there that you can get from
colleagues that they've made themselves
in their lab and that's fine but
generally I would say go with the
company because they've really validated
their antibodies well and have QC
quality control methods in place to make
sure they're the best quality like we do
also make sure that your antibody is
relatively new and within its stability
period and has been stored as we
recommend for instance at 4 degrees for
short term sometimes frozen at minus 20
is the antibody validated for amino
Saito chemistry or immunohistochemistry
you want to make sure your your
technique matches the antibody there's
law of antibodies out there for instance
there have only been validated for flow
cytometry or westerns so you want to
check that with your supplier very
importantly consider the host species
you want to Mouse primary you want to
rabbit or you know whatever species they
come from you want to make sure it's not
same as your tissue that you're labeling
or you're going to label endogenous IgG
s and your tissue and you want to match
it with your secondary antibody and I'll
talk about secondaries in a moment
finally do you go with the direct
conjugate that has a dye already bound
to it or go with and unconjugated and
then detect it with the secondary
antibody for microscopy we generally go
with the secondary antibody detection in
order to get the best signal to
background
direct conjugates are very common and
flow cytometry where the instruments are
more sensitive but sometimes you can use
them on cells tissue usually has too
much background and you need a further
amplification here's a web resource
listed here where you can find a
antibody selection tool on our websites
be aware also that we will also be
providing a PDF of this presentation and
you can go to those PDF that PDF to find
these URLs and our resources that I'm
recommending second every primary must
be optimized separately well there's a
lot of protocols out there and and I
can't tell you how many times I talked
to customers who are using a protocol
that they've just always used with every
antibody and I'm here to tell you you
definitely don't want to do that because
every ant Y is a little bit different
there's even differences between lot to
lot variability from a supplier so you
definitely want to optimize the fixation
time and what's fixative you want to use
and the time for it very much the
concentration or dilution of your
antibody do you want one microgram per
mil or five or ten micrograms per mil on
your sample we usually want to try a
range of different concentrations also
incubation times it's not uncommon to do
30 minutes or an hour incubation time
with your primary antibody on cells
maybe several hours for tissue or even
overnight at four degrees which is best
for your antibody of interest often
there's recommendations from your
commercial source but you want to test
it on your own don't just go with what
they recommend because every assay is
different every sample is different and
though we validate our antibodies
carefully we can't always predict what
your sample will need and finally a
blocking solution to I mean I mentioned
different blocking solutions not every
block is the same
every antibody I won't go into antigen
retrieval much but just realized that if
there's a chance that your antigen
binding size has been masked for
instance by your fixative sometimes you
can treat your samples with heat or
pressure or certain buffer components to
unmask those binding sites there's a lot
of different protocols out there for
answers and retrieval and some good
review papers most antibodies don't need
it and sometimes your commercial source
will tell you on the right here you can
see an example where I've used too much
antibody to label this tubulin sample
and it's caused the loss of resolution
and over saturation using a 20 microgram
per mil this is with our anti tubulin
alpha anti tubulin detected with a mouse
anti tubulin and then a secondary with
alexa fluor 555 on the right hand side
you can see where i've used five
micrograms per meal which was right for
this sample and you can see some very
good detail there if your antibody is
too old or stored improperly it can
degrade over time leading to
precipitants in the tube or nonspecific
binding and your samples here in the top
you can see some examples of cells that
weren't so great on the upper left this
was that Golgi image I showed earlier
loss speckles off cell a lot of speckles
on cell nonspecific binding that the
blocking couldn't block if you use a new
antibody in this case anti Colton 97 you
get nice specific Golgi labeling on the
upper right you can see a tubulin
antibody that's degraded giving the you
the sort pearls on a string appearance
to the tubulin but a new one you get
very nice features like down below it
remember quality primaries means you get
a quality labeling of your antigen very
important and I often have people call
in here's tech support asking
there are a lot as a recent one maybe
they forgot to put the date on the vial
so it's good to check that step 3 and
our five steps is to detect your label
this is to detect with a secondary for
instance or an amplification technique
and what controls to use secondary
antibody usage is a very common
technique there's lots of review papers
again out there but how do you optimize
it this is where your unconjugated
primary has been detected now with a
secondary antibody that has dyes on it
you want to again go with a company that
you trust one that has good quality and
good quality control they validated it
for these methods make sure your
antibody is relatively new and within
stable period and stored properly very
importantly consider the host and target
species for instance if you have a mouse
primary you want an anti Mouse secondary
and a host that matches the serum that
you're using like for instance a donkey
anti-mouse secondary now if you're
combining with other primaries for
instance you have one rabbit primary and
one Mouse primary you want to make sure
that your anti mouse secondary is cross
absorbed against rabbit so it doesn't
cross label and label your rabbit
primary - and vice versa that your anti
rabbit is cross absorbed against Mouse
right so you can usually look into the
certificate of analysis for your
antibody to know what it's cross
absorbed against or in the manual for
that antibody or just call us here at
tech support and then do you want it to
be dye conjugated or biotin elated or
enzyme conjugated we'll talk about
amplification techniques in a moment
realize that we have a web resource -
that you can select an antibody at at
this URL remember just like with your
primary you have to optimize your
secondaries every time one protocol does
not fit every assay again many labs have
a certain protocol they like to stick to
don't count on it you need to optimize
with a new sample and a new secondary
optimize the concentration usually for
microscopy we're talking between one to
eight micrograms per mil incubation time
is very important for cells it's 30
minutes to an hour for tissue it's at
least a couple hours sometimes as much
as four hours and you want it to be in a
blocking solution at least some BSA like
three percent BSA to again to helps help
prevent nonspecific binding or our
blockade solution that's quite good
remember just like with primaries
quality secondaries means better
detection and you want to be as specific
as possible let's talk a minute about
amplification techniques if if you're
not getting a strong enough signal with
a standard secondary detection you want
to amplify it higher above background
this is particularly important for low
expressing antigens or maybe rare cell
detection in your samples in the upper
left there is streptavidin biotin or
avidin biotin is another one this is
where you have a biotin elated primary
or secondary antibody and now you're
detecting it with this happen right a
streptavidin that has has been
conjugated to a dye when you use a
standard secondary you might get as I
show on the bottom there may be ten to
twenty dyes per target but if you buy at
enolate and label with a streptavidin
now you're getting twenty to forty dyes
per target so a much brighter signal
then if that's not enough if you need an
even brighter signal you can go with the
pyramide signal amplification
amplification or tsa this is where your
secondary is labeled with a horseradish
peroxidase and then the t remind reacts
with the HRT in the presence of a little
bit of hydrogen peroxide and then binds
covalently to terracing residues around
the sides of that HRP the
gives you hundreds of dies per target
much much brighter but there is such a
thing as too much amplification so you
want to consider the relative expression
of your target is it a high expressing
edge Jenner low expressing antigen
here's some examples on the top I have
tubulin tubulin is a fairly high
expressing antigen and really every
sample using a direct conjugate or a
secondary detection like a go to anti
mouse like in the middle there you get a
pretty good expression of tearing of the
tubulin in the sample but if you go with
TSA now you've oversaturated you lose
some resolution and it's actually too
bright you have to throw a neutral
density filter in to take that image
whereas if you're going with a low
expressing target like alpha catenin on
the bottom a direct conjugated or a goad
anti-mouse secondary was not enough to
detect it you're not getting a strong
enough signal over background but if you
used here might signal amplification now
you only have a 15 minute exposure and a
nice bright signal with good signal to
background recently we have released our
pyramid super boost kits which have a
poly h RP in other words there's more h
RP molecules on the antibody and that
means more reaction with the ter might
give an even stronger signal and you can
see some examples here of just how
strong it is and your 8 because you get
such a strong signal from your super
boost pyramid kit now you don't need to
use as much primary and secondary
antibody to detect it so we've you can
see some example dilutions here at the
top of your primary antibody and you're
able to dilute down to 1 to 600 or even
1 to 1,200 and still see specific
signals you definitely can't get that
with a standard secondary technique
remember amplification gives you greater
sensitivity let's talk for a minute
about controls and when I talk to
researchers some
they don't run all of the necessary
controls to rule out possibility of
nonspecific binding or nonspecific
signal so I've mentioned already a
little bit about this but let me make a
finer point of it so autofluorescence
right where your sample has a background
autofluorescence if you don't have a
control with no dye right no primary no
secondary you won't know how much of
your signal is due to the secondary and
how much is due to the auto fluorescence
so have a control with no dye whatsoever
that you've washed and mounted the same
way to see what that background signal
is but it's very high you'll want to
knock that down also having no primary
control this is where you only use a
streptavidin or secondary antibody to
detect but no primary but you've blocked
it the same way so here you're testing
to see if your blocking is is
appropriate or if the signal that you're
seeing is due to nonspecific binding of
your secondary antibody if so you'll
want to block better or maybe go with a
newer secondary and then finally if
you're doing multiple antibodies in your
section or on ourselves make sure that
you use cross labeling controls this is
where you use the wrong secondary on
purpose in a single color experiment so
if you have a mouse and rabbit primary
on your sample then you'll do a control
with just the mouse primary and just the
anti rabbit secondary hopefully you
won't see any binding but if you do now
you know that you have the possibility
of cross labeling and vice versa for the
other antibodies and anti Mouse on the
rabbit primary to see if there's any
binding now hopefully all these controls
will be negative you won't see much
signal at the exposure time that you
need but it's an important thing to
check when you're first starting and a
saying remember controls gives you
confidence in your results let's talk
about detecting your sample now we're
moving on to the dyes and some of the
hardware it's important you know there's
a lot of different diets spanning the
visible and far red and infrared
wavelengths how do you choose which dyes
to use well first off you want to match
the dyes that you have you want to match
the dyes that you purchase to the filter
sets and hardware settings that you have
available
fluorescein filter sets or light cubes
are very common in instruments so it
you'll probably have a green dye in
there like alexa fluor 488 or flora
singh in our fitzy that's very common
but your scope might also be configured
such that has a filter set for Daffy and
the blue for nuclear labeling maybe
Texas red in the red or a high three in
the red orange color or a far red dye
like Syfy for alexa fluor six four seven
our light cubes we we hear it
Thermo Fisher Scientific cell Evo sly
cubes for use with our Evo's microscopes
which I'll mention again later
and here you can see an example of those
light cubes and the lower-right or
traditional filter sets in the upper
right and the sort of band passes that
you see in this graph I realize that you
can sometimes have a problem with bleed
through this is where let's say you have
a green fluorescent dye like Alexa fluor
488 and an orange red fluorescent dye
like Alexa 455 555 or side three this
might be where one dye bleeds through
into the filter of the other dye such
that you see a signal what can you do
well up here in the upper right you see
an example of some cells imaged in the
green with the Lexus or 488 all you
should be seeing or punctate spots which
are the peroxisomes that you're labeling
but here you can see some bleed through
from the alexa fluor 555 phalloidin
those F actin filaments they are not
supposed to be there they're actually
leading through from the
read into the green so what do you do
about this well first off you can reduce
the dye concentration of the ascending
dye for instance in this image I would
want to reduce the concentration or
dilution that I use of the alexa fluor
555 such that it's not as bright and
thus doesn't bleed through as much
another choice is to use a different dye
combination so instead of alexa fluor
555 i would choose a guy that's farther
away from the green for instance elects
four five nine four which is in the
texas red wavelength or even a far red
dye like psy five or you can choose a
different filter set that has a narrower
band width most people don't have a lot
of filter sets to choose from so that's
not as reasonable of an option usually
or you can use some specialized imaging
software to subtract out one image from
another or special instruments but
usually those first two recommendations
are the best reducing dye concentration
or choosing dyes that are farther apart
we have a tool online called the spectra
viewer thermo Fisher dot-com slash
spectra viewer and there you can choose
numerous dyes and see their excitation
and emission wavelengths you can even
pair it up using that tool to display
what your excitation and emission
wavelengths are on your instrument and
using this tool you can choose dyes that
best fit your filter sets and be able to
see just how much bleed through there
might be between them how much they
overlap how much the dyes might bleed
through into the filters that you have
it's a very useful tool and I highly
recommend that you go there to check it
out remember careful dye choice means
that you have clearly separated labels
and specific labels okay moving on to
step four in this webinar to get a
publishable image you want to protect
your signal you've labeled with a dye
and now you want to make sure that that
dive signal is bright and well retained
the most important
aspect of that is your mounting medium
so after you've labeled yourselves for
instance what do you do well you usually
you put a cover slip on it sometimes if
you're imaging in a well that's not the
issue you just want to image in a buffer
but if you're using a microscope there's
a good chance that you're going to put a
cover slip on there and what do you put
under the cover slip
that's your mounting medium for
fluorescent samples it's very important
to use an anti fade mounting medium when
you exposure your dies to a very intense
light on the microscope photo bleaching
will occur this is where the dye becomes
dimmer as you're looking at it that's
because the strong light is degrading
the actual structure of that dye causing
it to not fluoresce as well an anti fade
mounting medium has an T fade components
in it that slow that photo bleaching if
you want to mount image and then discard
your slide then you want a mountain that
has a good refractive index right away
like our slow fade diamond and slow slow
fade gold products they don't firm up
that just stay liquid but if you wish to
archive your samples if you want to
mount them and image them over the
course of several days or weeks then you
want a mounting medium that cures or
hardens for instance our prolonged
diamonds and prolonged gold products
hardened to a firm gel this means that
there will be less off rate or slower
off rate of the dyes and antibodies on
your sample and just gelling alone slows
the movement of reactive oxygen species
and such that can contribute to photo
bleaching and you want to choose a
mountain with a very good refractive
index refractive index refers to the
bending of light hasn't moves between
substrates for instance the light goes
through your objective the glass lens
going to bend slightly in the air and
then bends again and the glass and then
bends again and your anti-fade mounting
medium so you want something that's
closest to glass with the refractive
index as close as possible to 1.5 - such
that there's less bending all that
bending of light means you lose
intensity and lose resolution and
usually you want the brightest signal
you can get and the best resolution
possible
you'll want a mountain that does not
quench the dye of interest for instance
effective shield will quench far red
dyes like Alexis or six four seven so
you want to make sure from the company
you get the mountain
what dyes are best in that mounting
medium and which ones are to be avoided
our prolong and slow fade products work
with pretty much any dye and are
optimized for our electro floor dyes as
well
prolong Diamond even works with
fluorescent proteins
unlike most and then consider whether or
not you want to solvent based mountains
like Saito steel sixty or pistol mount
that we sell or if you want an aqueous
based Mountain like our prolonged
Diamond usually the best choice is to go
with a aqueous based this is where you
just move your samples from their last
wash directly into the mounting medium
without having to dehydrate or move your
sample through solvents as is commonly
done with colorimetric dies like
hematoxylin in the usin fluorescent dyes
usually don't do well with those
dehydration techniques so definitely if
possible go with an aqueous mounting
medium here's an example of that photo
bleaching that I mentioned in this
gallery you can see that in the bottom
row is just PBS with glycerol and this
dye which is a fluorescing or fitzy
phalloidin photo bleaches away and
becomes dim very quickly whereas if you
use prolong gold or even better prolong
diamond you see that you retain your
signal over that entire
minute now I mean it doesn't sound like
a lot of time but it actually it's quite
long for imaging and you need time in
order to orient yourselves and and find
what you need without the dye just
disappearing so choosing an anti fade is
important but what else can you do well
you want to reduce the light intensity
and the duration that it's on the sample
because the more light there is the
stronger the light the longer the life
and more photo bleaching you have so you
want to be quick about imaging about
setting it up if you use a traditional
microscope you might even throw in a
neutral density filter while you find
cells of interest now if if the cell if
your dye is just so sensitive that photo
bleaches away really quickly even in an
anti fade then you might want to
consider having a second dialog Debbie
for instance that you can use to find
yourselves and set it up and then you
quickly switch over and take the image
in the dye that's not as stable remember
your hardware settings play a role too
exposure time the longer your exposure
time the more photo bleaching will get
for those who like data here are some
graphs that show photo bleaching these
are normalized to their initial
intensity and you can see over time that
the intensity decreases or goes down as
you see the lines here yellow is just
PBS and for many samples that's the
worst but using an anti fade mounting
medium like our prolonged diamonds and
green here you can see that you're able
to retain the signal much better over
time we have a selection guide online
that you can use to help choose an anti
fade Mountain you can see the URL here
remember using an anti fade Mountain
means you have a more stable signal in a
longer-lasting signal to give you the
best signal to background okay finally
let's talk about the fifth step in this
webinar this has to do with your actual
imaging part when you say get a
publishable image often people
that that has to do just with your
actual imaging on the instrument but as
I pointed out the first four steps here
are actually everything before that
what's the point in imaging something
that's not already optimized with all
those other techniques your image isn't
going to be publishable unless you're
able to do all those optimizations ahead
of time but now let's talk about the
instruments and the software and
hardware first off here is the you can
see an image of a typical objective lens
that's used in a microscope there's a
lot of different aspects and choosing an
objective but generally you want to go
with the best possible objective usually
an apple chromatic or f apple or super
apple chromatic is your best because it
corrects for chromatic aberrations and
color and planar Apple II at aberrations
so it's all about getting a image that
is nice and uniform and Co localizes
between colors very easily and of course
you want to consider the magnification
how high do you want to go using oil
will give you a brighter more resolved
image but of course oil has its own
issues I won't talk too much about
choosing objectives here beyond that but
what are some things that you need to do
about objectives and the lenses in order
to get the best most publishable image
well first off make sure that your
slides and coverslips are clean and dust
free before you begin your assay and
that your objectives are regularly
cleaned and inspected because you don't
want dust or debris or buffer that's
been dripped on it to reduce your
resolution and choose your objective
lenses wisely as I mentioned also the
light source in your instrument most
traditional light sources are like a
mercury lamp which you have to align you
have to make sure that your lamp is well
well aligned and of the right intensity
with your system or in confocal systems
aligning your lasers
mercury bulbs do go bad over time so you
have to consider their age and stability
at the bottom if that black and white
graph is sort of an example of how the
intensity decreases over time and then
you have to replace the lamp and it's a
little unstable at first then it
decreases over time our evo systems
don't have that problem also align your
condenser if you're doing transmitted
light imaging the condenser lens under
the stage for an upright scope or over
the stage for an inverted scope has to
be aligned and have what's called Kohler
illumination that's where they at you
Center the condenser and try to get the
best illumination and those lenses have
to be cleaned - here's an example of a
traditional microscope where in the blue
line you see that the light the
excitation light for fluorescence
travels from the the mercury bulb
bounces off the dichroic mirror in the
filter cube and then down to through the
objective to the sample on the stage the
dye then gives off a wavelength that's
higher like in the green line here that
goes back up through the filter set to
your eyes or the camera in the red is a
transmitted light from tungsten bulb for
instance that goes up through the
condenser through the sample and then up
to your eyes or the camera there's a
picture of a Nikon scope at the bottom
as an example however what we sell here
are the evos microscopes
Evos microscopes have a lot of great
characteristics about them one is that
well first off there's no eyepieces
right but also it has a very short path
length for the light which means that
you're going to get a brighter signal
and that's very important for a
publishable image get a nice bright
signal and it also uses a like you we
sell our evo sly cubes that have the
light an LED lamp built into it
so there's no more aligning of mercury
bulbs or having to replace mercury bulbs
or or discarding the Merc
in a safe manner now it's built into
that filter cube so you get a nice even
illumination every time without it going
bad it's good for 50,000 hours and you
have built into this light cube the
excitation and emission filters for that
family of dyes for instance the GFP like
you will have those filters for GFP or
fluorescein and you can see the same
this is an inverted microscope so you
can see that it's the opposite of what
the scope was I showed before where all
of the fluorescence is down below in the
bottom going up to your sample and back
down to the camera notice there's no
eyepieces so you're imaging through the
monitor at the top is a one of our Evo's
FL Auto automated microscopes and at the
bottom there is our brand new FL Auto -
the newer version of our automated
microscope here are some examples of
some hardware that has not been
optimized on the left is a image of some
Dappy labeled nuclei and you can see
that they're dimmer
on the upper right compared to the lower
left that's because this was taken on a
traditional microscope where the mercury
bulb was not aligned properly and so you
get a brighter sample if you were to
move this sample left or right on the
stage you would see that the field of
view is always going to be dimmer in the
upper right so you'd have to realign and
then to the right is a image of an
objective lens that has not been
properly cleaned you can see that
there's some dust and debris there which
will reduce your resolution and might
cause other optical artifacts and
sometimes fibers can be autofluorescence
as well you can also see a little bit of
damage to the objective there where is
scraped against the stage I always got
to be careful about that if you want to
learn more about our evos microscopes
there's a link for you at thermo Fisher
comm slash Evo's remember proper
Hardware means you get the most
efficient detection
now what now as you're taking your image
on your microscope usually you have some
sort of imaging software this software
helps you take the image and helps you
combine the different colors into one
and there's some and there's some very
important aspects to keep in mind to get
a publishable image one is that you want
to optimize the settings you want a good
exposure time that's not too bright and
not too dim sometimes you want to adjust
the gain setting this is the voltage to
the camera to get a brighter signal that
be careful too high of a game you can
cause some background signal too long of
an exposure time and you're saturating
too low and it's too dim also the light
intensity matters a lot with our Evo
systems you can change the voltage to
the LED usually you want to pretty high
to get the brightest signal possible but
if you're going to photobleach your
samples you can also just reduce the
light intensity by adjusting that
voltage on confocal systems you want to
optimize your laser intensity raster
speed and raster F average and pinhole
size also give some thought to the type
of file that you're saving you in most
imaging software you can you can save as
TIFF or jpg or bitmap you can save as
8-bit or 16-bit why would you choose one
versus the other so for instance of
8-bit images that's if you're saving
color or if you're saving annotations
like scale bars for instance 16-bit is
better from monochrome images so if
you're doing quantitation 16-bit has
more data on it so you can get more data
out of your example remember though that
16-bit images won't open on many
off-the-shelf software like photo
photoshop or Windows image it will
appear black or dark because it's only
reading the first 8-bit images so to
open a 16-bit image you need to use an
imaging simha gen alysus software like
our celeste
software or NIH image J or Fiji here's
an example of image acquisition software
on our evos FL auto - instrument and
let's talk about the settings here so in
the lower right you can see where you
can adjust the light exposure and gain
but the image is quite dim but if you
increase those settings too much like
exposure time now you're saturating the
signal you're losing a lot of specific
resolution there because the signal is
just too bright with many software like
ours you can it'll actually tell you
when you've oversaturated pixels by
coloring it here you can see in blue the
oversaturated pixels and you'll know
that you'll need to decrease those
settings like the exposure time here's
an optimized picture I reduce the
exposure and optimize the light settings
such that you're able to see nice signal
without over saturating anything
alright good vs. bad images with those
settings here on the left is an image I
took on the FL auto - which is not
optimized at first you see some signal
I'm you see mitochondria and red nuclei
and blue and tubulin in the green but if
you look closer you start to see some
problems with it for instance there's a
little bit of blue haze in the
background and that's because the gain
setting was too high in the blue in the
green that's actually quite dim so this
is because I allowed it to photobleach
too much now it's very dim I didn't
properly use an anti fade and in the red
I've actually oversaturated it with too
long of an exposure time so if you
correct for those things if you take it
before it photo bleaches the green if
you reduce the exposure time in red and
reduce the gain setting in blue now you
see a nice resolved image with good
signal to background and the fills well
centered in the middle as well this is a
good image for
is bad remember optimizing your settings
means you get accurate data and a good
signal to background very important
so that's your image acquisition
software but once you've taken your
image you often want to analyze it on a
different software package your image
analysis software here at Thermo Fisher
Scientific we sell our select software
for instance but there's others out
there like Emmett's J or Fiji or various
commercial ones that you can use and
there are some certain characteristics
that you need to keep in mind when
considering optimized publishable images
here I pulled up a three color image
where I've taken each of three colors
blue green and red in monochrome 16-bit
images and I recolor eyes it using the
merge feature here here you can see in
the lower right the colored version of
that with all three colors but there are
some things that you can change and
maybe not in a good way for instance on
the upper part of this image in the red
block you can see that I can adjust the
brightness the contrast and the gamma
now it's okay to do that in some
circumstances maybe you want to bring
out certain features that you want the
reader of your paper to focus on and
that's fine just realize that you're
changing that picture in ways that may
not be ethical so you have to make any
changes very judiciously and I'll talk
in a minute about the ethics of imaging
now once you've taken your image how do
you measure it right a publishable image
isn't just about its appearance it's
also about the data that you get out of
it how do you measure that data well
here using our celeste software is an
image of some to some actin labeled
cells using a phalloidin well one way to
get the data is using a region of
interest and here you can see some
regions I've drawn around some air
is that represent bright signal versus a
background on the left there you can see
a circle that's the background that I'm
comparing against and all those other
regions are measuring the average
intensity of to get a value that I can
compare between samples now for a sample
like this one a region may not make the
best entry it may not be the best choice
because obviously I'm missing a lot of
label there by using a region of
interest and so instead I might use a
different way to measure using a
threshold antenna threshold adjustment
intensity so here I'm threshold again
blue those areas that are colored and
I'm adjusting the threshold includes all
the specific areas so now I want to
threshold a bit more and that seems to
be pretty good there now if you compare
from before you can see that there's
some areas that maybe is covered that I
don't want to be covered in a few areas
that I'm missing but if I go too high
now I'm going to start measuring
backgrounds and black areas and
nonspecific signal that I probably don't
want to measure now one interesting
feature about Celeste is that it has a
smart thresholded and you can actually
teach the system what's specific and
what's not so in the pale blue here you
can see the actin is very nicely
selected and none at the background
that's a neat feature of Celeste now I
won't go into all the features of
Celeste software here but I urge you to
learn more at our website there's a lot
of great function in that software
package including like 3d rip
reconstruction or all sorts of different
segmentation techniques and Counting so
if you want to count cells in an
automated fashion alright let's talk for
a minute about ethics and this is
something that is not actually covered
that much by other people out there so I
wanted to really make make up
point of it when is it okay to adjust
your image and when is it not most image
acquisition software will allow you to
adjust the brightness contrast and color
maybe you can crop it maybe you can
adjust you know your raw image and we
save it in a certain way that's okay but
there's some guidelines you need to
follow never add something to your image
that wasn't there in the first place
except maybe some annotations like
arrows or scale bars never selectively
remove something from the image and
don't selectively enhance one area of
the image without performing the same
manipulation to the whole image and
usually whatever manipulations you do to
one one image in your series you'll do -
all images in your series don't compare
to images that have not undergone that
same treatment and don't crop your image
in a way that removes valid relevant
data even if it doesn't support your
desired conclusion I think we all who
have experience have known someone who
has broken some of these rules and it's
important to call them out on it and if
you do make any changes it's a good idea
to mention it in the captions of your
paper by the way that fell on the upper
right has not been manipulated those are
nucleoli in the cell labeled with our
psycho RNA select green I always get a
laugh out of that picture
remember ethical imaging means
trustworthy data and thus publishable
data so that's pretty much everything
that I wanted to go over in this webinar
here's some very important web resources
and web some sites on our webpages
that you can go to to learn more about
some of these characteristics the top
one is particularly useful for those who
are new to fluorescence our molecular
probes school of fluorescence which has
lots of useful techniques and and
information the pdf version of this
webinar will have these links and
finally if you have any questions or
need help with protocols please don't
hesitate to contact us at technical
support here
our web here's our email address and you
can feel free to ask for me Jason or you
can go to your website wherever you may
be in the world and go to the contact us
for support page and click on technical
support we have technical support groups
all over the world to help you I hope
that you've learned a lot in this
presentation about how to get a
publishable image and I'll be happy to
take some questions from you now thank
you for that presentation Jason we want
to get right to your questions and input
so here's a reminder as to how audience
members can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left if we were
unable to get to your question due to
time constraints Thermo Fisher
Scientific will reach out to you via
email and our first question is in what
way do the Evo's microscopes differ from
traditional microscopes well when you
look at an Evo's microscope the first
thing you notice is there's no eyepieces
you're looking at a screen all of them
use monitors when I was teaching
microscopy to beginning science students
inevitably the hardest problem they had
was just learning to look through the
eyepieces
and you have to worry about your glasses
and the eye width and all that so don't
worry about that with these scopes a
monitor is great everything's digital
also depending upon which model you
choose and we have six different models
of microscopes that you can see at
thermo Fisher dot-com slash Evo's Evo s
right there are different
functionalities for instance the Evo CFL
and XL allow you to do manual counting
by clicking on the screen to count your
cells and you can make movies and time
lapses with your images or with our evos
FL auto and FL auto 2 system which is
newer and has more features you can
actually do automated imaging so you can
put a plate on there set it and then
tell it to go and have an image maybe
once
fifteen minutes or every half hour or
whatever all through the night
especially if you have an on stage
incubator system which is available as
an accessory with those and so that
automated feature is great and you can
do these stacks with it and you can do
tiled or stitched images with it there's
a lot of great aspects and we'll do
demos and lab even so if you're
interested in the Evo systems you can
check out the web page or we can also
help arrange to put you in touch with
representative who might do a demo with
you great thank you for next question we
have I've never heard of charge based
background binding like when you talked
about the signal enhancer solution do
all dyes have this issue
hmm well remember this is about the
charge on the dye right so most dyes
have a negative charge
for instance the alexa fluor dyes and
fluorescein and those have a net
negative charge which will bind to
positive areas on the cells or tissue
but they're all a little bit different
in terms of how badly they'll bind there
are a few guys out there like Texas red
for instance which are Vitter ionic
where it has one positive and one
negative so a net neutral charge but
even they can have a little bit of
background binding due to charge so I
got to where I was using the signal
enhancer solution which I helped develop
by the way in R&D with pretty much every
immuno of photochemistry and
immunohistochemistry protocol I did it
never inhibited binding in it it always
seemed to help with pretty much every
dime okay my lab makes its own anti-fade
mounting medium why not go with our own
formulations hmm I've helped develop
some of the anti fade mountains here
either directly in Rd or as an advisory
and I can tell you we've tried every
possible homebrew remedy that we have
found that have been reported by labs or
put on webpages for instance
sometimes people use TRO locks in
solutions or in propyl gallate
but I'm here to tell you that or dab Co
they're not nearly as good as what we
have optimized I would definitely
recommend going with a commercial anti
fate mounting medium like our pro long
and slow fade products because we've
done so much validation with a wide
range of different dyes and techniques
wonderful questions coming in we have
time for just one more our lab uses RPE
for flow cytometry because it is so
bright is it also suitable as a dye
option for microscopy hmm good question
well our p or RFI core rim is very
common in flow cytometry because it does
have a very strong quantum yield and
extinction coefficient a very strong
intensity however it's not photo stable
even with anti-fade mounting mediums the
photo bleaching is very bad so you'll
label your sample you'll put it on your
microscope and the signal will go away
very quickly which is too bad but you
know what we've got lots of dyes to
choose from that are also quite bright
like our alexa fluor dyes and our dye
light dyes so I would recommend going
with those instead wonderful looks like
we're out of time for questions I would
like to once again thank Jason Kilgore
for his presentation do you have any
final comments no just check out our web
page at thermo Fisher calm and feel free
to email us if you have any follow-up
questions and we'll be happy to help you
thank you for attending
okay thank you again to jason coab or i
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand until May of
2018 keep an eye out for an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we
encourage you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues you may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again next time goodbye